Rickett morones is the founder of border
angels a pro-immigration group and he
joins us - enrique thanks for coming on
it's so I understand that you're for
more immigration into the country but I
can't imagine you would support people
walking across Mexico and just showing
up expecting to be let in if that were
to happen a lot we would no longer be a
country so what should we do with these
people
well Mexico is not a hostile nation like
you mentioned earlier of course the
people that are coming from snow of
course it isn't and the fact that these
people are coming from Central America
is the same thing that's been going on
since Reagan interfered in the Central
American policies in the late 70s and
80s these are people that are escaping
violence escaping hunger they're looking
for refuge and they're trying to come
into the country and when you have a
Border Patrol spokesman that Chris
Harris encouraging the come telling them
just show up at the border and say
asylum you're gonna get in that's a lie
that's not the way it works and it
causes these people to flee they're
crossing they think they're gonna be
able to get in most will not be getting
in why you I don't know why you would
feel an obligation to defend the
government of Mexico which is abetting
illegal immigration into our country
which has been literally for years which
has trained people explicitly with
documents that we have on how to get
into this country illegally I don't know
why you would be flacking for them I
don't know what's in it for you exactly
but let's stop lying about it Mexico
could stop this right now Mexico is a
very long country it's a long way from
Honduras to Tijuana they could stop this
but they're not this is an act of
hostility the thing is that we allow the
freedom of CREB people to be able to
travel freely within the country as a
lot of countries do in the world and I
will defend Mexico because you're lying
what did you show me a document where
the Mexican government is training
people that you just said to cross into
the United States the Mexican government
isn't doing that
are there people doing that there may be
really you know I'm sorry I think I win
with superior knowledge here no no
superior of course it is from San Diego
right okay yeah
government has given instructions to
people I've seen them with my own eyes
on how to get across the border of
people could be stopped
anytime by the Mexican government which
again you feel the need to make
apologies for but they detain people all
the time in their country from Central
America as you know but they're not
sustaining these people because they say
they're going to El Norte
so there are hostile power but why
should we have to accept anybody who
comes here most people aren't coming to
the United States most undocumented
people go elsewhere they have no desire
to come here of the 250 million
undocumented people in the world today
the United States has 11 million and
that flow has shifted dramatically
dropped 40% of the law why should I know
but you're missing why should we take
any they're locking the United States no
way for these people to come in Legally
in the United States interfering in
these countries the demand for the drugs
invading sovereign land like Iraq or
interfering the civil wars or Central
America that causes people to flee the
u.s. into the reason so you hate America
is what you're saying
very part of why actually it's your
stance you're blaming America for legal
immigration into America of America
Central America is part of America
Mexico is part of America is a separate
country that's not the same as Honduras
actually one-third of all Salvadoran
citizens already live in the United
States so at what point can we say we've
atoned for our sins in El Salvador did
option within the policies of other
countries stop taking their natural
resources stop invading sovereign lands
you have a president we taking the
national resources of Honduras Trump
remember Donald Trump I mean that guy
he's an embarrassment to the world he
says they're coming for dakka dakka
ended in 2000 people had to have been
here by 2012
Donald Trump doesn't asking you your
opinions on Trump I'm not interested I'm
asking you but the nobody said the hold
on the policies that affect all of us as
Americans then you're saying that
Hondurans have a right to come here
because we take the natural resources of
100
some how can you know a lot more
specific absolutely the invasion of the
United States of sovereign lands whether
it was the interference in Central
America with the Reagan administration
we do the whole delicious well every
word of iran-contra have you heard of
the fact that the United States is then
one consumer of natural resources from
other countries the number one consumer
interests us for bad things we did in
Honduras know everybody this doesn't do
you know and when they invade sovereign
lands when they take from sovereign
lands this should be a more welcoming
nation and they are not but there's no
people come in they're desperate is one
enough a rash over the world they just
wanna have a rational conversation they
should be yeah nobody should have ones
all right we should have to me when you
can explain what we did to Honduras to
deserve this